general mcchrystal are
those of you who have the
stunningly good judgment to take courses
at the Jackson Institute next year
professor McChrystal is going to have a
conversation with greg mortenson and at
the end i think there might be a little
bit of time for QA but it's all your
show so thank you so much I want to
start by thanking gym for letting us do
this today and thanking all of you for
being here and all 20 people for my
seminar and so raise your hands because
I'm making sure I got all 20 of them
here credit yeah exactly no this is
basic credit this is to get the solid
see I promised you so know what I want
to do is today is we're going to talk
about leadership and to do that in the
first two these conversations on
leadership I want to first thank you for
taking the time and caring enough about
leadership to be here and participate in
this with us because there's nothing
more important in my view than
leadership to start this series what do
you do when you want to get something
right to start you go to somebody that
you have absolute trust in and so I went
to my friend greg mortenson and we're
going to talk more about it today but I
will tell you that if you want to
measure the effectiveness of someone as
a leader see who they have touched the
thing I have learned about leadership is
when you find someone who can lead you
don't be afraid to follow them and so I
have done that with Greg for some time
because i figured i learned that he had
figured things out that i didn't and so
I am unabashed at admitting that as he
showed me effective ways to operate and
I think many other people I've gone to
him and I'm hoping today that will be
able to delve into some of what Greg
believes now I'm not going to give you
his bio because he's written a couple of
books but i will tell you greg is an
extraordinary leader because he
influences people without many of the
leadership attributes you might see on
TV I've never seen him grab anybody and
slam him against a wall I've never seen
him
because he could if he wanted to maybe
it's the implied threat it's their
mahaney and fleeting being but what he
has done is he's led from a moral point
of leadership and he has led by example
and he's led by persistence and he has
led by caring about people and relating
to people and so we're going to talk
about all of those things today the
other thing I would tell you he dropped
what he was doing on short notice and
flew across the country to do this today
and he's going to fly back tonight to
Montana so he came he did for you what a
lot of people would be too busy to do
and in fact he's too busy to do but Greg
I want to thank you up front thanks Gary
let me start Greg by just asking you to
describe for all of us what you think a
leader is and what a leader does well
besides our wives there are many leaders
and I we were talking earlier with you
there there's a lot of leaders here
potential leadership one of the one of
the happen those of you who are going to
Yale or other universities part of your
leadership experience is not and what
you're learning but in the connections
you're making and your your ability
later on to go on in the world is
through building relationships so I
think a leader one thing is I've noticed
a lot of leaders are they're able to
think out of the box some leaders live
out of the box another thing I think
that important and leadership is is not
being afraid to fail and make mistakes
one of the languages that I've learned
is called balti which is in northeast
pakistan and balti by the way doesn't
have even a script it's only an oral
language but in balti there's no word
for failure now in the u.s. we have a
hundred words for failure you know you
bomb out you screw up you flunk I mean I
can go
on and on but imagine in one language
there's no word for failure the closest
word for failure in balti is comparable
what it means is you've reached a fork
in the trail like a fork in your life so
and when as I see in the US when we form
strategic plans we form you know
budgeting and stuff like that but we
don't factor in that this world is a
very dynamic fluid world we live in a
everyday things are changing and
happening and not happening and so when
when we perceive it as having failed or
flunked actually in a different culture
in the mindset we've just reached a fork
in the trail and also in balti the word
for success means you've reached your
destination now I kind of like that you
know maybe we should get rid of a few
words in English help define leadership
and then the other thing is there's some
other things but one thing about
leadership to is that I learned from you
is I often thought of leaders previously
is somebody in the back pushing things
forward or somebody in the front with a
rope pulling things forward but I think
Stan wit you really believe in as the
leaders kind of at the in the middle a
leader is I used to be a climber and
women are sometimes better climbers and
men but it's because they climb from
their center of gravity and when you're
at the most pivotal point you can affect
more change or have more dynamic not
control but being able to do that and
also leader I think is is a really key a
leader is an empower somebody who can
empower the people that's what you call
force multipliers right in the military
and a person who is able to find people
who can be empowered to determine the
course of their life or a company or
business I think that's a leader yeah it
gets exactly we'll get a pass in your
lab now your 2c minus here minus okay
they said that's a good way yeah let's
talk about you as a leader there because
you were a soldier us
a student trauma nurse climber now you
lead a big diverse movement and an
organization how did you grow talk about
your personal journey well and I just
just for the sake of those yards dance
class I mean what when you teach the
students do you tell them what you think
a leader is or do you you just help them
define what a leader is or we try that
we try to everybody find their way how
they define a leader leadership exactly
see what I'm trying to do is figure out
figure out what do you talk about in
your class and so I so I can be more a
little more open about it I was very
lucky i was born in minnesota 1957 but
when i was three months old my parents
went to Africa and I grew up in Tanzania
tanganyika for 14 years in Tanzania most
people don't wear watches everybody's on
african time I grew up in a very diverse
environment I got to go to school with
Muslims Christians Jews Buddhists Hindus
Sikhs and as a child we used to roam
around in temples and mosques and
synagogues and churches and and that was
there was a lot of also celebrations
kind of cool you know every day is a new
holiday for a different faith I also I
went to school with children from two
dozen countries I think what from my
childhood everything that I gleaned the
most is actually through my father's
example my father set up a hospital
slopes of Mount Kilimanjaro called the
Kilimanjaro Christian Medical Center and
my father worked very hard to get a
hospital starting one thing that he did
was to make it a teaching hospital he
said a hospital on its own is worthless
if it can't teach the people themselves
to help themselves so and he also
insisted to have Africans in charge and
that rubbed wrong constantly with
Americans and the Europeans they said
you cannot you need a qualified
Westerner to run this hospital my father
said no we're always going to have an
African in charge it's kind of some of
what you did in Afghan
Stan you've always put the local people
in charge and when the hospital opened
up in 1971 my father was a commencement
he said he predicted it at 10 years all
the department heads would be trained
and from Africa and basically my father
got fired within one month for having
the audacity believe that this hospital
could be run by Africans and that's
pretty much why he got canned so we came
back to the states and my father
unfortunately died from cancer but 10
years later 1981 we got the annual
report from kc MC hospital and every
single department head was trained and
from tanzania and even today 40 years
later you could look at the killing jar
Christian Medical Center every single
Department had is from Tanzania and so
what that to me is an example is you
know all of us I think we we have an
innate desire to help people do to our
conscience or intuition or out of guilt
some but if we really want to help
people we have to empower people and
empowering starts with education and and
also I think leadership again is ability
to be able to empower people yeah it's
up a B+ or B minus we're working on it
do you get pass or failure to get a
greater no one's past yet oh no one's
past well they showed up exactly that's
half of it no it's it's interesting
because when we evaluate people in
different cultures as leaders often
there's a big gap they look differently
they groom differently they have a
different language they have different
habits and and I know I had to get used
to dealing with someone as a leader who
operated very differently than I might
operate let's talk about that for a
second particularly in Afghanistan and
Pakistan describe what a leader might be
like a typical leader in a village in
Afghanistan well one of the observations
that I've made or I've been able to
experience is women we often perceive
them as very oppressed in public they
seem to
here and there walking around like this
and they can't go in the bazaar etc but
if you go into that compound or house
you definitely know is in charge is the
matriarch the woman same thing in my
house and I don't know about your house
of the woman is in charge this isn't I'm
talking about the household but some of
the cultural attributes that I I think
specifically in the tribal areas of
Pakistan Afghanistan one is the leader
is able to somebody who can galvanize
the people and it's not a post but it's
somebody who's able to get consensus
we're able to another thing that
Westerners have a hard time
understanding is like in Afghanistan
especially in a conflict people change
alliances overnight but what it is is
for they've been fighting for 2,000
years so survival becomes more important
than important than winning survival and
survival is is making your alliance with
the the person who is in power or
perceived to be a power another thing
that a leader is able to do is I was a
highly I'd say become somewhat like a
chameleon and what I mean by that is
that leader can go into a foreign
environment that's not he's familiar
with and he immediately start looking at
how people sit how they're posturing if
you go it like in tryon and Pashtun
areas if you're given T we will we will
have tea but the host first should drink
the tea before you drink it because
they're showing you that it's not
poisoned so a leader would be able to go
in there and immediately notice that
nobody's drinking until the host drinks
where's you know we might go ahead and
you have that like that's really good
tea and everybody's like that's not a
guy's not a leader at sag there you go
ok now you
thank you not poisoning the water yeah
and and I think also maybe you could
help refine what I'm saying here but
from the time a child grows up and this
is also in Africa oh I grew up or of
council boxed on and in a village every
child from age three or four has a chore
the youngest kids might have to get
kindling wood for fire the girls have to
walk two hours go get water to three
boys are given responsibility for all
the sheep and goats in the entire
village imagine the entire wealth of
Yale depended on three freshmen guys you
know like for the day protecting against
wolves and Harvard predators and
everything else so and what that does
the responsibility is is huge and over
time the people who collectively know
how to best get everybody to do chores
but it's kind of like a beehive or
something everybody has a tiny part but
if somebody doesn't if one bee doesn't
do their job the whole beehive can
disintegrate um are you familiar with
how bees find a nesting area did when
bees they they go together and they they
find the hole for a new area to nest in
a hive but they have to about 50 bees
have to collectively send signals to
each other that that that area is okay
and also the entrance is big enough to
accommodate the whole the whole be and I
think that's interesting where wherever
there's not one leader but it's
collectively as a collective leadership
and also a leader also is able to look
at in Afghanistan or Pakistan a leader
often is able to look at a situation
from the other person's perspective we
often our leaders often we look at it
from our own myopic lens an example is
there's a common proverb
that the Afghan the shore the elders say
and it's it says Allah or God created
the earth and it was good and then he
took the leftovers and threw him into a
pile and that's Afghanistan or that's
our tribal area so we that seems very
sad least to me you know like well
you're just made up of leftovers but
they say he saved the best for last so
it entirely depends on what perspective
you look at the situation absolutely
let's talk about sense of community too
because that affects how leaders grow i
took senator Levin down to the Helmand
province not long after the elections of
2009 where everybody had complained
about levels of corruption and everyone
in the village had voted for President
Karzai and so senator Levin said
obviously he was a group of elders
probably 50 he said obviously we got a
problem with free elections here because
everybody voted for the same candidate
and they they spoke to and I said what
are you talking about we got together we
decided who we believed in and we voted
and it was a very natural thing they
decided that it was in their best
interest to support of Canada and they
couldn't see why you would split your
vote and vote different ways and they
were a little they took umbrage of
course at at senator Levin's question
about it but the idea of getting
consensus as a leader leading from the
middle and the shura process talk about
that little well it's very fascinating
the in Afghanistan and also in Pakistan
and some of the tribal areas a Shura is
an elder and every community has elders
every province has elders maybe very
briefly basically an elder they're not
elected but they've kind of risen up as
the leader an elder could be a poet it
could be a warrior it could be a
businessman there's also women we're
sure our elders and they are the real
autonomy or power in in the country or
in there
their area so they often went when
there's dispute often the sure we'll
meet in a jirga joerger is like a tribal
meeting and they will collectively
decide what to do and give you some
examples we'll pretend we're at Yale and
be same system here so if a somebody
from Harvard came to Yale and stole a
pickup when Mercedes I don't know what
I'm from Montana so pickups are valuable
I don't know pickups available here but
or whatever BMW has so anyways what
would happen is the elders from Harvard
and Yale would meet Harvard your rival
right kind of like okay at least
academically here so then the elders
everybody at heart would have to pay a
nickel or dime or quarter or dollar to
pay for the perpetrators crime because
that person represented the entire
Harvard community we came here to yell
in stole his Mercedes and afterwards
Harvard would take care of the
perpetrator themselves and often the
very severe harsh punishment or judgment
so here in the US often we act as
individuals you know we kind of came
from the John Wayne society and when we
do something we don't really think about
our community or school or or something
else we're thinking about ourselves as
an individual but they're thinking
themselves as a collective community and
the person who violated the strength of
the collective community that person
often is very harsh judgement something
else that may be in a tribal society so
say Stan you and I had a land dispute
and we were fighting and our
grandfathers fought about the same land
so what we do is we say hey we really
want to solve this problem so we get out
of APB for all the elders to come and
meet us and the elders come and they sit
in a jirga often you don't and the Jirga
until you've come up with a resolution
and so say we we can't get the elders to
agree even so then we agreed to fight so
but we set some terms of engagement
we're not going to kill civilians we
only fight for sunup to sundown we're
only going to you know whatever and but
then if Stan if you win the battle which
you obviously would but you killed two
of my men you have to take care of those
men those widows and orphans for the
rest of your life so it puts a price on
human blood shed and forces arbitration
often the most powerful militia
commanders you'll see their compound has
20 women and 100 hundred orphans but
what it does is also when you're
fighting you're not going to you don't
want to kill and waste everybody because
that's going to cost you a lot of money
and also responsibility for for taking
care of those widows and orphans I think
it's important to understand I mean even
terrorist groups you be dealt with al
Qaeda spends a significant portion of
their funding on the widows and orphans
of fallen terrorists and we sometimes
don't realize that but that there are
some strong bonds and that's not a a an
Afghan or Pakistani culture tends to be
more more Arab let's talk about if
someone says America needs you know the
pound the table and they say America
needs to show more leadership in them in
the world or in the region and they turn
to you and they said okay Greg tell us
how to do that what would you say how
does America how could America have more
leadership show more leadership and oh
yeah well I would say we need to go
drink more tea but I mean that's my pack
can't answer but what I what I would say
is we absolutely need to build more
relationships in the world and we we
operate in a very sterile environment
you know all these texts and Twitter's
and laptops and everything but without
relationships we really can't do very
much in the world and Americans although
it's it the irony is that our country is
great because of its diversity people
have come here from all over the world
we've created this in crime
double country you know visionary
country but yet now we having problems
building relationships around the world
and I encourage kids students ever a lot
of you have parents from other countries
are here from other countries but I
don't know if you agree with me but I
think that is where the u.s. is really
faltering them for example Afghanistan
we put a lot of tension on Afghanistan
but Afghanistan from a tribal
perspective it's a regional problem
people find it absurd that we don't have
any diplomatic dialogue with Iran we're
trying to solve the problem in
Afghanistan they also find it absurd
that we're not involving the countries
around their country to help put
pressure as a collective community so
I'm just speaking on behalf of the
people there but relationships is a key
I think where we America could use more
building relationships and the irony is
some of you wonder why that I spend time
with a military I'm first of all I'm a
veteran but and if you read three cups
of tea you'll find out actually I was
fairly critical to military after nine
eleven i went to the Pentagon twice and
i said they're all laptop warriors
there's no boots on the ground we have
smart bombs but nobody speaks Pashto
hardly anybody speaks Arabic there are
relationships but I can tell you what
I've seen in the last decade evolved is
probably of all our government entities
the military has put a huge priority on
building relationships and and they
really get it and understand it and I've
been able to see this unfold over the
last decades it's 911 and our top
military commanders most of what they do
is go around the world and build
relationships and I think one of the
good things that President Obama did
after when he came into power is he kept
like secretary gates Admiral Mullen Erik
Olson and other people rather than
change everybody he kept people who had
relationships over there a little bit of
that happens also the State Department
but pretty much you know all of our
ambassadors were changed after the new
pres most of them after
new president comes and when you throw
it away are these people have amazing
relationships with the country
absolutely what I'd like to do is open
it now for questions from any of you and
if you come up to the mic and we'll take
a shot at our ideas or ideas criticism
or suggestion no criticism oh it's okay
a good leader has to take some good
criticism to her exactly how's it going
the sanitizer I'm undergraduate here and
um I was wondering from from both of you
guys how you thought South power could
be used with regards to sort of the cost
benefits of spending and with your types
of schools versus sort of more I don't
want to use a word extremists but
extremists madrasas i can start one of
the things interestingly i came to do
believe is we probably should have
funded madrasas inside afghanistan now
that would be a very difficult thing to
do but if you look at the Madras it's
it's a way for people to get a greater
understanding of the Muslim religion the
biggest problem with extremism typically
as people who are not schooled in the
religion and so you had very very
narrowly focused madrasas typically in
Pakistan funded from outside that
produced students who were extremists in
many cases they were memorizing the
Quran in Arabic but they didn't speak
Arabic and so the meaning was entirely
up to someone who told them what it
meant and of course that person could
spin it either they want so I think the
idea to me of soft power is empowering
people with knowledge it's empowering
people with the ability to help
themselves now there are times when you
need military force and other things as
well but at the long term I think the
best thing we can do is empower people
and I certainly defer to Greg on I'm i
agree with ahmad raza means at school
and ninety-nine percent of madrasas are
like a catechism or
Bar Mitzvah you know that kind of
learning about their faith but one of
the things that we do in all our schools
is in addition to what we basically
teach for languages in addition to their
native tongue which is Arabic English or
do or plasto or diary or whatever
language or Farsi and but we teach the
kids how to read write and understand
Arabic and that's the difference between
the madrasas that that propagate violent
ideology is as Stan mentioned they do
not know what they're they're reading
and in the Holy Quran nothing says girls
can't go to school the worst two sins in
Islam are killing of civilians and
suicide the first word of the revelation
in the holy quran is ocurra it Cremeans
read and the first two chapters in the
revelation if you if you kind of
translate them it says go out into the
world and seek the truth it means go out
and get an education basically so and
what the extremist Imams do is they try
to keep people isolated and illiterate
and when you've got isolated elder
people then you can really control
people so do you ever incorporate sort
of these more positive aspects of Islam
in your schools oh definitely we have we
teach as I mentioned four languages
where required by the government to
teach islamiat studies it's about three
hours a week both boxing Afghanistan and
then we get criticized people say well
how can you teach islamic studies I said
well we're following the law but what we
do is we we find very qualified Imams to
teach the real you know what what Islam
is really about and it's um you know
it's maybe in the u.s. it seems a little
bit strange but they're they're really I
guess I mean were there's another way
you know one of the things that I've
been able to see is the Taliban and
militant groups their primary recruiting
grounds are from illiterate impoverish
society
it and it is one reason is because when
when a you know this is not Islam but
part of society there when someone goes
on jihad and jihad means a quest it
could be a spiritual endeavor jihad
could also mean academic or can be
joining militant group but generally
they should get permission from their
mother first if they don't very shameful
or disgraceful so if if woman has an
education she's much as likely to
encourage your son to get into violence
or to terrorism and I've seen that
happen as I mentioned that one of the
primary recruiting grounds is from ilary
and private society because it's it's
much more difficult say when women are
educated there they also they also tend
to promote you know their sons to get
education and jobs and other things it's
not the main reason but it's part of
what happens with education nice the
real enemies ignorance and ignorance
breeds hatred in any faith you know I
think ignorance people use people use
their faith to to to incite Wars it's a
you know both both yes I think that
ignorance applies all over I think one
of the greatest weaknesses we that
threaten us is our own ignorance often
we operate in an area without knowing
the history without knowing the
geography without knowing the culture
without knowing the personalities and
when you don't know you're playing blind
man's buff and you could be with the
best of intentions in the world but if
you just don't know you're going to push
the wrong button pull the wrong lever
support the wrong person that sort of
thing out of ignorance and so I think we
need to understand better and take the
time to do that well jump over hi my
name is Jessica triscoe I'm a visiting
fellow at Yale this year but I'm
actually Canadian so we have a slightly
different perspective on what's going on
in Afghanistan especially because we're
now in the process of disengaging
militarily but a report published by
oxfam Canada yesterday found that indeed
the the schools and the development
projects that were investing in
that country are not only more expensive
than those being produced by the Afghan
government but also more subject to
being targeted with violence and I was
wondering what your experience this was
in your own schools how they're
perceived within the community and also
why you think that your best practices
and also the best practices of the
Afghan government are so divorced from
those of the international forces thank
you well thanks um and just just shout
out to the Canadians I'm the in 2002
2003 the first troops foreign troops I
encountered were Canadian troops and I
found it rather unusual that they would
go into the villages and they were
meeting the elders you know I thought
soldiers are supposed to go and fight
and so it and there was a general Frank
Hillier who was a Canadian commander he
actually he was kind of bringing stuff
that you kind of brought around but at
an early point the Canadians were really
involved that in part of it is because
Canadian have been peacekeepers troops
around the world and so that's a little
bit in there they call ethos or what and
I know in Canada I've been privy to some
of the discussion in the you know in in
Ottawa about the troops or not and
everything that's very true in the last
three years more than about now three
thousand schools have been destroyed by
militants in Pakistan of gas on what's
interesting is there's two things one is
about three-quarters of schools of girls
schools they're not boys schools and
their targeted not only because
foreigners built them but because
they're a girls school and I find it you
know interesting that you know why are
the Taliban or other groups why they so
terrified if little girls going to
school because I think their greatest
fear is not a bullet but it's a pen and
they fear if that girl goes up gets an
education you know the value of it
they have lost their ideological way to
control society that also was the way
you know I our schools are totally if
you ask none of our schools have been
shut down or destroyed and if you ask
any village about that school they'll
say this is our school they won't say
it's Central Asians to they won't say
it's Americans ballistas our school and
how we do that is and we've done this
since day one is when we set up a school
we provide the teacher training and
support we provide the materials like
Samantha the skill labor like Masons
carpenters but the community has to
match at 5050 they have to give free
land free manual labor which is like
eight thousand days of free manual labor
and then free resources like Sam so what
that does it's 50 we call 5050 but they
have local buy-in and communities that
have had put so much into their school
they're going to protect their school
they're also going to nurture it and
they're also going to be invested in in
the outcome of the school so and that's
that's the problem that most of school
is being destroyed nobody knows you know
it's an outside contractor they never
involve the local community they didn't
get any sweat equity from the community
they also nobody knows how much money
was built to build a school they don't
know who got the money and the schools
that aren't destroyed there's also
hundreds of schools beautiful brand new
school you drive by you to go down four
kilometers and there's twelve hundred
kids sitting in the dirt you say how
come you're not in your new school and
the principal say well we didn't get
orders to go there then you ask the
district education officer how come you
didn't open up a school he said well
there's a problem with the contractor in
Kabul and the contractors I didn't get
paid so I'm not handing over the keys or
whatever and the problem is from day one
they never involved the community and
and that's the biggest thing it is
changing in the last two or three years
community and may give you my you know I
think the best example this is really
leadership
the best example of community the best
aid group working in Afghanistan is
called sorry no national solidarity
program nsp and what nsp is two percent
of the Afghan federal budget of the
Afghan government their federal budget
they cut a check to each of the 396
districts for maybe two hundred thousand
half-million the district decides how
they want to use the money they all have
to match it and if you go to any rural
area this is totally run by Afghans
there's no foreigners involved except a
few you know advisors and that is the
best project going on Afghanistan
there's no it's funded by the World Bank
by the way but no outside involvement
and the people that is the most viable
project that I think is going on in the
country today and that's why you know I
think if every country in the world
could just give a million dollars or
hundred thousand put it in an SP project
we would have to have all the troops are
right now absolutely yeah hello my name
is wash Masada and I'm from Kabul
Afghanistan I wanted to thank you for
what you're doing to help my country
five years ago I was sitting under the
Sun trying to learn my ABC just like in
the video I consider myself
exceptionally lucky to be able to find a
teacher and a supporting family later on
I learned that my desire to get
education was overlooked people were too
busy giving it important to the bigger
stuff trying to understand Afghans
descriptions for Afghans were illiterate
warriors villagers anti-education if
that's a word even and extremists
growing up I practice my English words
by writing them and the edges of
newspapers and dreamed about having
notebooks and pens I'm sorry I wrote I
wrote it because I didn't want to get
nervous
and having a classroom was too high of a
dream for me I wanted to thank you for
not over looking at my desires and those
are currently in Afghanistan I wanted to
also thank you for actually
understanding my country my people and
the importance of education in
Afghanistan also thank you for
understanding the true meaning of Islam
in is teaching finally thank you for
inspiring me to become who I am and
where I am right now thank you so much
see him I think she can come up here in
exactly he's a leader that sucker I'm
thinking a plus did you in general give
you mr. Mortenson my name is Greg
Bernstein I'm a cadet from the US coast
guard academy I first want to thank yell
for having us here this ruthless here
the back so thank you very much my
question and I guess a little bit of
commentary as well is about a recent
speech from the USAID administrator Ravi
cha about like hondas competition of
development saying if we're really going
to do this we're going to kind of change
the perceptions of development that it's
going to have to take military obviously
general NGOs State Department across the
board if we're going to do that we have
to change a culture that says we're not
about replacement or work you know we're
more about replacement that we are who's
doing development best you know my
firm's been here this long I'm investing
this kind of money and when you get to
more of an idea that our whole point is
to replace to be replaced over time
right by local institutions so how do
you think general and also mr. Mortenson
that we get to a point where we're about
replacement we're not necessarily about
this competition of development thank
you well thanks and maybe a mannequin i
can i can share a story it's actually
about general McChrystal Stan you have
to call him general obviously that ain't
call you staff it was it skits maybe and
this isn't political but I was trying to
show how Stan really tapped into exactly
your question not not in relation to
NGOs but in a bigger kind of concept
about empowering people when President
Obama was elected as you know they were
trying just the attention he said
Afghanistan is going to be our top heard
again we ran off to rock for six years
but then President Obama so we're going
to make F Gaston a top hurry and then he
asked general McChrystal and others you
know how many troops do you need to do
what you need to do
and but so what he did is over time
general McChrystal asked for what 35,000
or you got 35,000 and and so then
immediately Capitol Hill said okay now
go do something we got it do something
we double the troops we have double
investment go out and do something so we
can bring the troops home and what Stan
did right when he got to Afghanistan one
of the first things he did is this is
really important he asked he asked me
and couple other people said I want to
meet with the elders of the provinces
there are 34 provinces enough gasset I
want to know what they think about all
this and again the pressure came from
Capitol Hill they said you've got to do
something and so what was planned was a
massive big military operation was a cop
eration home entering a no maid means
hope in Pashto and the goal of Omid was
to drive a swath through southern
Afghanistan to flush out all the shadow
government's that correct detected sir
so but what so we over time facilitated
meetings with 19 of the 34 provinces
enough gas and with the elders with
general McChrystal and his advisory team
well what the elders told Stan and I'm
kind of consolidating but one of the
things they said is if you do this this
is very foolish you don't have first of
all you're going to take a lot of
casualties number two you don't have any
relationships with these people you're
trying to go and help you don't have
networking you haven't galvanized the
sport of people so this is really fully
so what Stan did is I don't know how you
did this but you somehow you delayed
operation you delayed that big massive
operation against much pressure from
Capitol Hill and he said we are going to
first drink tea or we're going to build
relationships we're going to get the
people galvanized and then maybe we'll
consider this well over time you know
time let on and then in June general
McChrystal left and he was replaced and
then again the director was given now
you've really got to do something you
know we've we need to do something so
being pulled the troops home
and basically General Petraeus very
quickly he pretty much can the whole
idea because he said we're going to
really focus as general McChrystal did
on building relationships and people
don't didn't quite get that in capitol
hill and I I think it this was the first
time that the elders had really been not
only heard and listened to but their
voice actually affected a big decision
about a military operation so and I
think that it's that's really important
at least from my perspective that
finally the elders are being considered
in what happened was last June and
President Obama he wanted he summoned a
meeting Capitol Hill to he want to know
what are the elder saying now the irony
is he asked the military to tell them
what are the elder saying in Afghanistan
now if I was president obama i would
have skype the elders at least but you
know he didn't he didn't have the
technology you guys do i guess but and
then the next month july second to fifth
guess what President Hamid Karzai did he
decided I better listen to the elder so
he summoned a big meeting it was called
a peace conference but basically he
wanted to copy what general McChrystal
and what Obama done so 1200 elders went
to Kabul and there wasn't too much there
was a lot of talking but but that to me
really represents the integrity as you
mentioned the good Afghan people that
that really the solution is their
solution and they can they can do it but
we have to we're there to empower them
we're not and to help them we're not
there to tell them what to do to how to
have peace or does it make sense I
didn't answer your question directly but
I gave you an example yeah let me jump
on that because I think Greg's the
Central Asia Institute's effort to build
schools is really a microcosm for how
you need to help any region or people
and that is empower them to help
themselves but hold them responsible to
do that which means you have to engage
them and you have to give enough help to
let them do things they might not
otherwise be able to do but not so much
help that you are
doing it because the OL action that says
that someone gives you something the
first person you hate is them because
you you grow to resent that any
dependent relationship has that I think
what happens is this is difficult
because people with all good intentions
honest and idealistic or in a position
where they want to have progress as
rapidly as they can a counter insurgency
is a struggle for the soul of the people
the insurgents are trying to create a
situation where people think that the
government cannot provide security
economic hope for the future justice the
government is struggling to try to
convince the people that they can
provide that insurgencies normally go on
a long time because that struggle takes
time and yet anyone is paying a lot of
money and bloodshed what not once at the
end as quickly as possible as anybody
would so something that takes a long
time there's great pressure to do it
more rapidly and so as you try to do it
more rapidly sometimes you do things in
a way that actually can be
counterproductive you put too much money
into an economy and you create inflation
or you create disproportionate wages we
have a lot of cases in afghanistan's
where teachers doctors and other
professionals leave that profession
because they speak English and they
become interpreters or drivers and of
course that at the end of the day
actually undercuts progress because
they're critical to the nation so it's
this push do it quicker or or get it
done right and they can work against
each other even with people all trying
to get the right outcome there's no no
evil on that side it's just competing
requirements and this is something I
think people don't always understand
that's why Greg's model is so effective
because it's durable and I think it it
really gets to the heart of it one of
the I'm picking on Stan little but I
just wanted a leadership by example but
one of the meetings we arranged with you
I don't want to embarrass you here but
it was from the auras gone or as God is
in the south
very conservative area it's probably say
more volatile area so the elders really
wanted to meet Stan and I so finally we
had a meeting and Stan headed in his
back patio behind your command center
stan had gotten t and everything for
everybody and people he was busy on a
phone conference but so there was about
eight elder somewhere is gone and some
of your advisors and then stay on comes
out and everybody you know says he
starts saying hi to everybody but Stan
notice that chief elder [ __ ] Ibrahim
did have a teacup in front of him and
you know everybody else there was busy
drinking tea and everything but the
first thing Stan old it is is [ __ ]
brahim does not have a teacup in from he
went he kinda went like that and your
sergeant immediately read and gave a cup
of tea but that changed the whole
outcome of the meeting haiji brahim
today's is one of the champions of
Education horas con province and it had
nothing to do with what you talked about
basically wanted more armament and you
said well we have to talk about this
more but but because immediately what
Stan came out he noticed that [ __ ] /
didn't have a teacup in front of him I
mean that seems really simple but it
actually changed the whole dynamic of
the whole meeting and [ __ ] room to this
day I mean he would follow to the ends
of the earth stand because he noticed
that he didn't have a teacup in front of
them so it is is anyone who's from
Afghanistan knows the Afghan people are
extraordinarily warm so it's not it's
not that I'm a hospitable person because
not always but but I will tell I never
went anywhere and I went a lot of places
with President Karzai and we'd go to
meetings whatnot and then i would go
alone places from little villages to two
very senior people and i never had a
place where the individual there was an
extraordinarily solicitous not only
about whether i was taken care of but
also about all the people with me about
how junior they were I mean it was just
a natural warmth and grace and genuine
hospitality that really is important
because it infects I mean
if you start with that it's sort of hard
to be more partisan as you go forward I
think the the something critical to that
we don't think about is things you know
I meant three cups of tea the name of
the book but it's actually very
important part of any transaction their
first engagement with somebody or
interaction you don't talk about your
business you don't pull out your
spreadsheets and your strategic plan and
your budgeting everything what you do is
you get to know each other and they'll
find out you know how is your son doing
and is your wife happy that you're gone
from home 10 months and what's your
favorite kind of tea and then and you
get to know each other and I will know
that maybe his daughter has epilepsy or
his mother passed away three months ago
and and then the next meeting you might
hint at what you're trying to accomplish
but generally it's it's three meetings
and then you can start going at it you
know here we walk into a board meeting
or something we don't know each other we
pull out all our spreadsheets and
another thing too is when you know
somebody you can you can also empathize
with them but you also have leverage on
them because you know that like they're
kind of vulnerable position right now so
I mean I can move on them right now so I
mean I'm just I'm sharing both sides of
this 50 and it has to do with
relationships it's how things can happen
in in most of the world the u.s. we were
an exception to that I mean we most
board I say business transactions we
hardly know anything about that other
person we just know about you know can
they make some money and is this
business look good on paper but we don't
know that their great-grandfather's got
a billion dollars and he's going to bail
them out if they fail or something yell
in the class that they were sharing
together the leadership class one of the
points we make is in a meeting two plus
two does not equal for it equals
whatever the people in the meeting
decided equals and that depends on
relationships last night we had a
simulation of a national
council meeting and we were lucky enough
to have dr. mal vesti there who's got a
lot of experience in the National
Security Council and the point we made
his relationships in the room are an
incredibly important dynamic it's just
not mathematical you don't come in the
best policy outcome is not always based
upon this particularly great logical
objective look at it it's based on
relationships and what not and that's
not a bad thing but it really underpins
how important it is that you develop
integrity you develop real durable
relationships with people because that's
how things get done not nepotistic alee
but trust at the end of the day it is
trust and I think that's what you have
built so amazingly she was young sorry
um my name is Julia I'm an undergrad and
I guess I have two related questions on
sort of our role in Afghanistan as as
outsiders um the first was just I think
I can probably speak for a lot of us
saying that I read you know your books
and was really inspired and my first
reaction was like oh my god how could I
get involved and do something like this
and and then sort of the more you think
about it the more I think well you know
what role do I have anyone to do that
what what right do I have to UM to do
that so I guess and the first question
being what advice both of you have four
people at Yale or otherwise that are
around our age that are interested in
this but obviously don't want to be
crossing lines that shouldn't be crossed
and and that sort of thing um and then
the second is is sort of a similar
question but at a larger level I'm
taking a few classes right now where the
professors are really pushing sort of
what role do we as the u.s. have to to
try to win over hearts and minds and
what role do we have to think that that
we can build schools and they won't be
bombed and they'll be and and all that
and so I guess what I'm wondering is how
you guys respond to arguments like that
because it's something that I've been
having trouble sort of you know making
it really coherent response to well
as far as advice you many of you might
be aware of this but there's a huge
revolution going on in this country the
last for three decades and that is with
community service and service learning a
US News and World Report the magazine
came out maybe five years ago it said
that in 1990 only eighteen percent of
college graduates said I want to go out
and make my community or the world a
better place you know today it's fifty
percent and if you go down in the high
schools and junior High's despite
everything that we think it's even much
higher than that and it's not only and
what that does is not only to me it's
very inspiring and what that does is not
only say you know we want to help or
serve people but it also gets us to
think more as a collective society some
of my very practical suggestions are
first of all I think everybody should be
bilingual in this country in order to
understand that we live in a global
society I also think you know if you
have problems then don't go out into the
world to solve other people's problems
fix your own problems first also if you
want to go out and serve in the world or
help make yourself a really strong
person one of the things that I've seen
people who've been in the military or 30
years or people in service professions
or humanitarian work a lot of them after
one or two decades it kind of burned out
they get cynical and they're like
shooting themselves in the foot and you
think why is this person who's committed
his life to serve a country or humanity
why they like this and the reason is
they're not taking care of themselves I
mean emotionally physically mentally so
one of the things that you can do in
college is make yourself a really strong
person you know mentally physically
emotionally and then use and abuse your
resources your your professors and
advisors they're willing to bend over
backwards to help you but very few
students today
really reach out to get help and then
some other things are if you have a
desire to help people first of all find
out what is your passion you know what
it doesn't matter whether it's
Afghanistan or planting trees or
recycling or whatever it is but find
something that really is near and dear
to you i found what i'm doing today cuz
i had a sister who had epilepsy i was
going to get into epilepsy research but
look what I'm doing now but and maybe
this sounds little you know may sound
strange but I have a quote of my
bathroom mirror and I've had it there 20
years it says when your heart speaks
take good notes and I think in the West
we're too linear and logical we're very
strategic but if I look back in my life
the best decisions I made were based on
my heart the worst decisions were made
up here now don't just go around the
world following your heart that that's
going to not get you anywhere mitt I
think maybe one other thing that we can
learn from the children of Afghanistan
and Pakistan the people there is I think
what I really admire one thing about in
noffke sandbox I'm people have a very
strong sense of intuition and I have
high regard for intuitive judgment but I
think it's because they're unplugged you
know we have laptops and cell phones and
ipod people on go around campus with
their iPods in there when de Tocqueville
came to the US in 1831 there's anybody
here history people here de Tocqueville
came here from france to study the
prison system because the french somehow
admired the US prison system but what de
Tocqueville did would he [ __ ]
immediately sets is he said Americans
know each other they're good neighbors
they go talk to their friends they spend
time with their neighbors and that was
the main thing he wrote in his hole we
called thesis it had to do very little
with prisons it had to do with Americans
get to know each other they build
relationships
but today you know if you even coming
here from walking on Yale half the
people have music in their ear you don't
know your neighbors I'm not accusing you
of anything and and I really think we
need to unplug a little bit weak
technology is an amazing tool but
sometimes we need to just get unplugged
whether it's just a few moments or
sitting on a rock or whatever it is and
I find a lot of the elder Mujahideen
these are the most respected fighters in
Afghanistan and they often will go sit
on a rock or sit by the river and I say
you're really busy you've got hundreds
of people you have to arbitrate for and
you're sitting on a rock and I said well
you don't understand because I've been
at war and you don't know what it's like
but the reason I do this it gives me
validity when I have to fight and do
horrible things because I can have this
moment of silence oh I don't that
answered you give you any advice but
sorry great yeah thank you my name is
Jonathan I am an undergraduate here
first thank you both for making the time
to share experiences with us uh actually
your answer just now touched on what I
was going to ask which is both of you
you know operate or made decisions in
situations with a lot of uncertainty
certainly general McChrystal a lot of
life and death decisions on large scales
and you talked about how you know the
the Afghan Wars had this moment of
silence they found these they had these
ways in which they developed a certainty
to act and sort of be confident what
they did and for both of you working in
more I guess coming more in Western
environments where culture may not be
the same it made the hecticness of how
we do things may not allow for that kind
of time how do you still manage to find
within yourself the certainty to do the
things that you do and sort of sleep you
know sleep soundly at the end I Wow yeah
he still better than me in that
department exactly um I guess the first
thing you do is you never find certainty
almost every decision you
take and particularly the longer you go
the more they become uncertain you learn
to deal with that you learn together
what information you can you learn to
understand that you are going to assume
risk but in many cases what's most
difficult for leader is you are not
assuming risk for yourself you're
assuming risk that others are going to
ultimately except you know failure for
either casualties or failure in an area
or if we make a mistake and wordy wat to
harm a civilian those are all things for
which you are assuming the risk but
others are paying the price and that has
a that has a significant impact on you
can it can affect people in different
ways it can cause you to to sort of
clench up and not be able to make
decisions it can cause some people to
come very callous and try to wall off
from themselves the cost other people
are paying and therefore to take put
blinders on and move forward most
thinking people and compassionate people
don't do that for everyone it starts to
wear on you the the pressure is
cumulative and one of the things that I
watched and other leaders was the
pressure it's like a big weight on you
and it's not that you get better at it
you just get weighted down and what
helps you stand is relationships it
comes back around every individual has
good days bad days good hours bad hours
no matter how successful they've been
and what a great position they're in
there are times when they are weaker
than other times and the difference
there is the network of relationships
that you have people who believe in you
it can be family from far away it can be
comrades up close it can be across
cultural relations where people just
believe in you and I become a great
believer that you establish a a web of
those relationships and that's what what
helps you do it because there's no way
you can make the job easier or the task
easier it's just you can make yourself a
little bit better by realizing you're
not a lone actor nobody's that strong
least nobody that I have medicine
strong want anything I think just having
one thing that I've been blessed is able
I've been able to meet a lot of leaders
whether its political or people in
leadership positions and I don't stand
about you but a lot of them do mansion
they feel it's kind of lonely there and
also it becomes more difficult sometimes
to as you try to push something
unfamiliar with people you feelings go
very deep and then to to pull it becomes
lonely in and how those people is they
will say the same thing that Stan just
mentioned the only thing that really
keeps some people going is there little
network of their friends or their the
people who are really going to help them
see that vision and another thing is
maybe you could reiterate on this little
bit a leader as I mentioned also
somebody's not afraid to fail or make
mistakes and sometimes I think people we
don't know when to quit when we're
failing we keep going on and on and we
but we really need to stop whether it's
a business or a military operation or
you know in some kind of humanitarian
dever um sometimes what you envision or
what you've worked for it's not going to
work and how many how many how many
failures does it take before you stop
doing more harm so because sometimes you
cause more harm than good so um but I
think that's a really important point
you mentioned my relationships sometimes
you do fail as Greg said you just got it
you gotta admit it we have tried this we
failed and it might be it might be your
figure and one of the things I think
leaders have got to do is come to grips
with that because failing and being a
failure are two different things you're
a failure if you don't pick yourself up
and move forward because people are
relying on you and sometimes you're
going to fail and sometimes you're going
to fail kind of publicly sometimes
you're going to fail very painfully and
really I think the measure
a person at that point is how well they
they pick up and move forward because
that's when people need them thank you
both thanks so my question was very
similar to his I was going to ask you
about the difficulty of making the
difficult decisions and I was wondering
if you might be able to simply
illustrate difficult decision you've had
to make in your careers from your own
life and give some you know personal
discussion of the thought process you
went through and what made it difficult
and how you dealt with it afterwards um
sorry light is on you well I'm going to
go back to I mention the beginning my
wife yeah a lot of people have influence
over me but when I think when the most
difficult decisions I always ask my wife
and it's not because I want her just
opinion but it's because I need she is a
very good judge of kind of how morally
deep I feel convicted to that decision
and she can also she knows about you
know if that conviction will cause me a
lot of anguish or something of making
that decision and you you want me to
give example failure or more just about
a difficult decision or whatever you
know like like mystery tours feeling
well I fell you know what the first
chapter three cups of tea is called
failure and when I submit the original
manuscript to the publisher in New York
they said Greg you never start a book
with the word failure I said you know
what we all make mistakes and we all
fail them I flunked my first driver's
license test in college a played
football we won any ideas into national
championship but we lost one game that
year we're behind 16 x 17 there was just
a few seconds left and all I had to do
to be the hero and when the game is kick
a 20 air field goal which is really easy
anyways um I missed
and I also I almost failed in the first
school and was because I was doing
something that we call micromanagement I
had my receipts of my plum line records
and I was determined i'm gonna get the
school built and after three years a
little what happened one day the chief
[ __ ] Ali said if you really want to get
the school built you have to sit down
and be quiet and let us do the work and
take over and then I was really
horrified and then then then what he did
is he took my receipts my records he
locked him up he said there inshallah
allah or like everything will be fine so
oh this is it you know night i I was
getting ready you know three years I've
given up everything I've sold everything
I owned and no school and guess what
happened in six weeks the school got
built and not only that I jail he
brought me a ledger it's an old bridge
accounting system they had to come for
every single rupee that gone into that
school building end and i read that was
my turning point i was on the brink of
failure and I realized that I I was
there to just empower the people I I had
very little to do with the school
getting built but and I'm you know I'm
very fortunate an old man illiterate man
you know who's chews tobacco and
drooling and he had you know his hairs
all frizzy but he was the guy said you
need to sit out to be quite and we're
gonna do this and that's how that's
pretty much why now we are able to do
what we do i I'm just a cheerleader and
and it's the people that are doing
everything yeah I will love I'll jump on
that as well with two because sometimes
things that seem like difficult
decisions are really not as difficult
when you back away we when I was in
commanding special operating forces we
had a very sensitive and difficult
target that we wanted to to conduct an
operation against and I went all the way
up the chain of command to get
permission to do that and got it and we
fail and with a significant loss in
credibility for the force and about I
don't know a month later we
been continuing to work the opportunity
arose again and the question was if we
were going to try to go back up and ask
for another shot at this knowing that if
we failed the credibility might really
hurt us in the long run or whether we
were going to go and it seemed like a
very difficult decision but what I
actually thought about it I believed in
the force I knew what we existed for I
knew what our mission was and that was
to do this kind of thing therefore it
really was not that hard I had to assess
the operational part but when it came
down to we had always said if we had
these conditions we would accept the
risk and go and so he did clearly the
most public difficult decision I made
was offering the president my
resignation but when I really backed off
tonight wasn't a difficult decision
there was a situation when the press was
reacting to the Rolling Stone article
regardless of how I felt about the
correctness of that article at that
point the furor was enough to make the
president's job more difficult and
threaten our mission in Afghanistan my
my mission in life was to help the
mission in Afghanistan succeed and as
long as I remembered it wasn't about me
and it was about that was actually a
pretty easy decision that doesn't mean
it's not painful it just means it's not
hard to make it when you can step away
and say what am I really about what am I
here for thank you very much your head
hi I'm Susan O'Malley a lecturer here in
writing and film studies and overall
troublemaker but as I sit here listening
I'm wondering what message these elders
may have for us in your experience
because the United States right now what
we have a professor hacker here is
written a book called winner-take-all
politics in the over the last 30 years
the transfer wealth from the very
highest to the very very very very
highest so some of the problems that we
might want and students might want to
change around the world as you mentioned
earlier
you haven't fixed them in our own homes
yet and so we need to tend to that also
and maybe you could shed some light on
leadership that way thanks sue and you
asked what are the elder saying that or
what where are some their ideas is that
well maybe we should take home not only
ideas for how to help other people in
their countries but maybe they have some
examples for us that would I'm you know
we're not exactly having consensus in
the United States right now we're not
able to move forward in a lot of the
ways that we would like to and that our
students have the heart and wills to do
so how do we make our system work could
we learn something from from Afghanistan
it is that clearer yeah well I think one
is we could use a huge dose of humility
that's my personal opinion and what what
I mean what the elder when I talk with
elders including both men and women some
of the things they're saying is we would
like to be involved in the decision
making we also have solutions they're
also saying if you don't like somebody
or we don't like somebody we can take
care of it you don't have to call High
Command and try to do something and then
and then again and again I mean it it it
always or generally goes back to
education we really need education they
say we don't need firepower but we do
need brain power and some of the things
the US is doing we're putting a huge
amount of money into training the
military and a police force there but
it's only been the last year and a half
or two years since general McChrystal
was there ninety percent of police force
are illiterate eighty percent of armies
illiterate
and it really doesn't you know if you're
there not a letter then you might as
well trained some thugs I mean it's it's
literacy it becomes an important part of
law enforcement or whatever and so some
of the ideas that I've had now that from
the elders are for example in
Afghanistan they've discovered over
trillion dollars of mineral resources
like Mallette vm cadmium copper lithium
lithium is in all of our cell phones and
right now China's boycotting lithium
sales the u.s. the only other country
where it is available huge amounts of
Bolivia and so it costs about a million
dollars per soldier per year to deploy
in Afghanistan set about right so why
don't we pull six troops we'll have a
press conference in Kabul and we'll
build a school of mines and technology
in Afghanistan so that in 20 years
Afghanistan will have their own mining
engineers they won't be exploited by
Iran China Russia even the US I asked
the minister of higher education dr.
Farooq war doch who is an amazing person
how much would it cost to fund the
entire higher education apparatus of
Afghanistan there's 24 universities at
dr. war doc said 248 million dollars so
why don't we hold 248 more troops santam
home will fund the entire higher
education system of Afghanistan and you
know it sounds really simple but there
would be huge meaning in that and and it
wouldn't affect the military opera 248
troops you could probably spare them
right and but again it has to do with
just visible tangible ways of really
showing the people that themselves that
we really trust them and I don't know
it's these all these idea i get from the
elders these are from talking these
aren't my ideas and I don't know I'm
know if that really answer your question
or not or did you want to know I gets
great i think you should work on the US
budget
oh sad souls I think we were really over
time let's take these two questions and
then we'll wind it up okay thank you
both for speaking with us today my name
is Luke blend i'm a senior Yale College
you both spoken a lot about
relationships and interpersonal
leadership on an individual level I'm
curious if you think the dynamics change
when you reach the institutional level
do does the institution of American
society or government or military need
to show leadership to the Afghan people
what does that mean and what are some
ways perhaps that the Afghan government
can do a better job of leadership for
its own people what would you mind
answering that question how how can the
do you mind how can the American
government show leadership to the Afghan
people is it what would that be all
right if you're from Afghanistan and
what things do you think the US could do
to show maybe not to show leadership but
really empower the people does that
right and I thought she'd know baron you
or me we should head her up here at the
beginning yeah see this is our second
cup of tea now sweet little more can get
some business done here i don't think
i'll add more you already answered the
question it is the education lack of
education is why people don't have hope
I mean talk about you know a 16 year old
boy who exposed himself on a street why
because he doesn't know how to read how
is he gonna judge what's right and
what's wrong so whatever he does is
because somebody tells him who also
doesn't have education so the first um
the main answer for this question is
education and you already answered the
questions I don't really know I can
never thank you thanks yeah
I I would on the organizational side I
would say we shouldn't let individuals
behind behind organizations
organizations sometimes have cultures of
their own and people will get within a
culture or an organization of
bureaucracy and and sort of respond that
way and I think we ought to try to break
out of that when you are where you are
representing an organization you also
gotta represent it as a person accept
personal responsibility as well as for
the organization i think we'd go a lot
further in many situations if we could
do that one of the things when a week
before Stan left Afghanistan he met with
the elders from Nuristan province which
is it's it's in the north but it's a
very haven of a lot of extremists and
very volatile area but it's also that
many people there and there was general
McChrystal had to justify why we putting
troops there were taking a lot of
casualties in it there's not many people
there but it's because it's a big
trafficking area eventually after you
left they pretty much pulled a lot of
troops there but he met with the elders
from Nuristan province a week before he
left they had a great meeting with a
calm Dash and some of the other elders
so weak after Stan left Afghanistan the
same elders went to meet with a Taliban
and there was a lot of head-scratching
here in the US and people were like
confused and you know we were talking
about a seamless transition and here the
elders are running off the Taliban but
see they perceived a void in power and a
relationship so they immediately went to
somebody who they felt who would be in
power and it doesn't matter they're
there you know their ideology it's there
there they want to survive and the elder
and it's not that your replacement I
mean he's the commander but but they
have no relationships with him they also
didn't know what he would do would he
would he back up what he said he would
do like general McChrystal so and in the
u.s. very
confusing like okay so like now now that
he's it's not that the position is
important like or the institution but
it's the personal relationship they had
and even to this day you know this is my
opinion but the nurse town elders feel
very isolated they they haven't been
invited back to really engage with the
command center and the government so
they feel very marginalized and now it's
becoming a big haven for for terrorism
and it's because you know just one
relationship but it's really interesting
just I just have seen that happen now
over the last you know year thank you
thank you last question um my name is
Yaya and I feel kind of honored to be
the last question but um along the lines
of what you've been saying about
education being the basis of leadership
and solving our own problems at home
before thinking too much about solving
problems abroad what would you say to
people who are building and reforming
schools in the US and what have you seen
in the schools that you've built that
you'd like to see more of in schools
here people know I start because I live
in the DC area and it's a real struggle
in DC it's been pretty pretty well seen
I think its responsibility and I think
that's when we when we let the school
drift away from the families and
responsibility for the outcome then
everybody can point at well it's the
school system or it's this or it's that
or whoever until you can't I people
responsibly to the outcome I think it's
very very hard to to get what you want
out of that and so I would do everything
we can to get back to what greg has done
greg has tied the community to the
school because they wanted so badly and
we've got to seek ways to tie it more
tidy and I know that's easier said than
done but to me that's the holy grail of
this there is some I I've is a 120 140
schools a year both public and private
schools and being from Montana so we
have one room country school houses so
as
many of you might know the the
matriculation rate in the u.s. right now
is seventy-six percent and then like DC
it's probably forty or fifty percent
this means somebody who starts first
grade is going to graduate from high
school and the dropout rate is high
there's teachers aren't given
credibility they're not paid enough and
but i have seen another thing that could
be done fairly easily is what we do in
afghanistan a lot is we use older
students to mentor and peer the younger
students there are some it's being cut
now all the school budgets to there's
like joint third and fourth grade or
first and second grade and those are
amazing i know if you had did any of you
go in a joint third fourth grade or
fifth grade six so what do you think
about it do you think it helped having
being the underling and then being the
role model and so that thing is it
doesn't cost hardly anything but it's
being cut out of all the school budgets
now because we have to make cuts
something else that i could skew one
example i was a in near hollywood is
called a viva girls high school there's
about a hundred eighty young women there
in high school all of those women have
been in jail or in prison or
incarcerated and the principal there
told me if she put any of those young
women back in prison it cost california
forty six thousand dollars a year to
incarcerate you know woman for a year
and for fourteen thousand dollars a year
what has happened at aviva girls high
school is in the last five years not one
single graduate has gone back into the
judicial system and three-quarters or
graduates have either gone on to votech
or college the other quarter got married
or something but and that have to do
with two teachers in that school who
really kind of brought the whole thing
around in a great principal and so you
know that's an extreme example but if a
group of eva girls high school can take
women
have been in prison who been in trouble
the law who had failing grades you can
do it there you know he can do it
anywhere in the country so there there
is and I think it has to do a dedicated
teachers and and also putting trust and
faith in that people can can make a
difference great but we have a we needed
a lot of help in this country with our
education system that's for sure let me
thank you Greg for taking the time